each year a new painting is featured on
federal duck stamps that waterfowl
hunters are required to buy
over the years the stamps have raised
more than a billion dollars to protect
wildlife and our nancy chen shows us now
how a social media savvy artist is
energizing this long-running tradition
[Music]
guys i'm kira i'm an artist and one of
my passions is the federal duckstab
competition which here fennel's passion
is contagious this is what i'm going to
paint if you want to watch along you are
certainly welcome the young artist now
has millions of views watching their
every brush stroke as they embark on the
quest of a lifetime could you have
imagined this all from a painting of
ducks no
some geese flying in the air no
it was definitely not what i thought
people would be interested in fennel who
identifies as non-binary has been
documenting their progress on tick-tock
i did some backtracking yesterday which
really pains me but after talking to a
few people and thinking about an
imaginary sun i decided to get rid of
the shadow on the neck it wasn't really
reading crafting their painting for one
of the most important prizes in wildlife
art it's so prestigious the competition
is known as the million dollar duck
because of how it elevates the careers
of contest winners
many people only learned about the
existence of this annual competition
from the film fargo three cent stamp
you're mallard
yeah that's terrific but it's actually
been around since 1949 it's the only
juried art contest sponsored by the
federal government first price winner
joe hoffman winners don't receive any
compensation beyond bragging rights but
the 25 stamps raise about 40 million
dollars a year for wetland conservation
nationwide how did you hear about this
contest
originally my grandpa
said hey you know that's actually a
competition and i was like oh really
fennel immediately got their ducks in a
row and started painting this is now
their third time competing most people
who win or most people who enter are
older men
who are in the hunting community and i
was like oh well this hasn't really been
tapped by my generation it'd be cool to
be one of the youngest people a female
or non-binary or anything like that to
just participate
this year the 22 year old who lives near
minneapolis raced against the submission
deadline it's coming along nicely i
really like the wing there are nine days
but if i want to be realistic seven
fennell bringing followers along as they
documented their entry spent up to 100
hours painting it the tick tock clips
with cameos from the cat elton took off
introducing a new community to fettel's
work and the contest itself all right
duck people today is the last day both
eleanor and burley have been filled in
but i do still need to work on burley a
bit i thought
hunting art
it just didn't really mix with
the typical population on tick-tock but
they were like wow that's dorky that's
cool
i love it the new found viral fame has
brought with it an unexpected spike in
sales of their artwork fennel says
they've made thousands of dollars for
prints from their etsy account with
orders coming in from as far away as
australia and iceland just based off of
this tick tock yeah my
views and purchases and orders
definitely spiked right after that it's
like the 2021 version of the million
dollar duck yeah
all this before a winner has even been
decided a panel of judges will pour over
entries usually numbering more than 100
and make their pick later this month but
fennel says being able to raise
awareness of the contest has been
victory enough
i've definitely already won i've done so
much more that i even hoped to in the
beginning
and i'll just be excited for next year
for cbs mornings i'm niti chen in inver
grove heights minnesota
you